there is new information out from the
legacy establishment media
on the cause of that horrific crime that
took place in waukesha wisconsin you
remember
the scenes dozens and dozens of people
injured six people killed
including a little boy
lots of senior citizen women injured
and killed for that matter
so the washington post
has a tweet out about this about this uh
attack
quote
here's what we know so far on the
sequence of events that led to the
waukesha tragedy caused by an suv
those dam suvs those psychopathic suvs
those hate-filled malevolent suvs cnn
says quote waukesha will hold a moment
of silence today marking one week since
a car
drove through a city christmas parade
killing six people and injuring scores
of others a car drove unless we're
talking about a tesla cars don't drive
people drive cars
so the car the car what did the car
drive maybe it was a tesla driving an
suv maybe that's what happened wikipedia
had an entry for the quote 2021 waukesha
christmas parade car crash oops just a
car crash like someone ran a red light
they had another article for a 2021
waukesha christmas parade incident it
was just an incident no it was an attack
it was an attack by a reported black
nationalist a radical leftist a blm
supporter who
hated white people who hated jews which
we'll get into we've got now his social
media history he had a political
motivation and he attacked civilians
and it would appear that there might
have been some relationship between
those two things he was a violent thug
criminal he was not an suv
the new york post has a report out on
the waukesha killer turns out he really
didn't like white people lots of pro-blm
posts a lot of pro-black lives matter he
was a mostly peaceful mass murderer uh
he here's just some of the some of the
posts
so when we start that good by the way
good luck translating this into english
but i'm just reading verbatim
so when we start back
knocking white people tf out iron wanna
hear it
the old white people too
knock dem tf out period
okay i think i vaguely can interpret
that next one hitler knew who the real
jews were the negroes are the true
hebrews so this is
a line that has been pushed by various
black nationalist groups including the
hebrew israelites or i think nation of
islam pushes the same kind of thing
this is the group you'll you'll remember
or maybe you won't if you were only
reading the establishment media when
nicolas sandman the smiling kid in the
maga hat at the lincoln monument
when he was being accosted by that
lunatic native american guy there was a
group of black nationalists screaming
slurs at him they were part of the
hebrew israelites if you've ever lived
in new york or washington dc you've
probably run into these guys at a
certain point they believe that the jews
are evil and they're like the fake jews
and the black people are the real jews
and he i guess this guy was was part of
that
this guy said that world war iii would
start when people learn hitler was right
and did the world a favor by killing
jews and you are not going to hear this
from establishment media outlets you're
going to hear it on my show
and
i guess in the new york post maybe from
a handful of other places maybe
you're not going to hear it from cnn or
nbc or abc or any of the others
the reason i bring it up is not not just
because of what a bad guy
this guy is
it's not even just because of what bad
irresponsible media outlets
the new york times and washington post
and abc and nbc and all those guys are
part of the reason i bring it up is
because it shows you that privilege and
oppression
do not work in the way that we are told
that they work
right we are told
that
white people and men and certainly white
men and certainly straight white men oh
my gosh
straight white men are the most
privileged people in the world who get
away with whatever they want to get away
with and face no adversity whatsoever
and they are repressors who get to get
to do whatever they want
we are told that black people and
hispanic people and other kinds of
people and women and homosexuals and any
other group any marginalized group
they have no privilege they are
oppressed
and
uh
pushed to push to the margins right
they're marginalized and they can't
really do anything because of that evil
straight white man
and yet when a straight white guy acts
in self-defense
against a mother beater and a pedophile
who are trying to murder him in kenosha
wisconsin
he is
lynched by the public opinion mob and
put on trial and very nearly loses his
entire life
when a black guy when a black
career criminal
who is a black nationalist who hates
white people who hates jews
drives a car and kills a dozens it will
injures dozens of people and kills half
a dozen people
you just you don't really hear about it
that's privilege
right
and the straight white guy that's
oppression
this gets back to a point even beyond
just lamenting how backwards
the uh perception of our culture really
is
it gets back to this point of a
sociologist i mentioned last week renee
girard
who who believes that scapegoating who
believes that the victim mentality and
mechanism is at the heart of culture but
he makes this point
you never know
when you're the one scapegoating none of
us do
myself included none of it we just are
not aware of it and you can see it in
other people but you it's very hard to
see it yourself and because the left
controls the whole culture right now
it's easier for us to see it in them
they don't realize
that uh
that they are scapegoating that's
obviously what they're doing because
when you're scapegoating someone you
always think that you're on the side of
truth and justice and the good and
what's right i'm glad you liked that
clip now hold on before you go
ring the bell please please that'd be
great ring the bell subscribe you
theoretically will get notifications to
these videos and if our pals at big tech
don't want you to you definitely should
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe for free to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]